متاسفه لسماع هذا الخبر لكن دعنا نتحدث
قليلا بشويه تفاؤل انت موجود الان في
الخليج لاطلاق مبادره جديده لدعم اطفال
فلسطين حدثني عن هذه المبادره
سواء
لمنطقه الخليج منذ 25 عاما اتي الى دبي
وكل الامارات العربيه المتحده للكويت وقطر
والبحرين والمملكه العربيه السعوديه على
مدار ربوع قرن وبفضل الدعم الذي تلقيناه
من هذه المنطقه من كل الجنسيات بمن فيهم
الاماراتيون والكويتيون والسعوديون انشانا
اقسام سرطان وعنايه مركزه وانقذنا حياه
عشرات الالاف من الاطفال فقط مؤخرا في رام
الله انهينا بناء مركزي عنايه مركزه مخصصا
للاطفال بفضل تبرعا من اسره كويتيه
والعام الماضي بنينا ايضا مركزا مماثلا
مخصصا للرضع في مستشفى الجنين بفضل اسره
اماراتي وانا هنا من اجل استمرار تدفق
الدعم لان الحاجه في فلسطين تتجاوز
مواردنا
نحن نؤمن بان توحيد الناس واظهار قيمه
العمل الذي سيتم القيام به وان حاجتنا
تحتاج اليهم وهم سيتجاوبون معنا وسيساعدنا
لو تخبرنا عن الوضع في فلسطين خاصه انك
يعني تعيش في رام الله وتتنقل من رام الله
بعد تجدد العنف خبرنا عن الوضع هناك
انا اقيم واعمل في فلسطين على مدى اكثر من
ثلاثين عاما على مدى الانتفاضه
العنف التي شهدتها المنطقه
والازمه الحاليه تعد من الاسوا انها كذلك
ليس فقط لان الفلسطينيين ما زالوا يموتون
يوميا وما زالت اراضيهم تنتزع منهم يوميا
ولكن ايضا واساسا لغياب الامل والافق الان
على مستوى سياسي سواء دوليا او حتى من
داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه بل وحتى
الفلسطيني ولذلك ف ان الحاجه الى منظمات
مثلنا تهتم بحاجات الناس وتساعدهم على
شؤونهم الحياتيه واليوميه والضروريه تبدو
الح و اكثر ضروريه من اي وقت مضى